Bernie Sanders had been the Democrats
frontrunner going into Super Tuesday
even though he did not win the most
states on Super Tuesday he is likely to
take home the most delegates from the
important state of California Nancy
Cordes is in Sanders hometown that's
Burlington Vermont where he voted
yesterday Nancy good morning how is the
Sanders campaign reacting to these
results
well Tony they are choosing to focus on
the positive that strong showing in
particular in California and Sanders
continues to insist that at the end of
the day he will be the Democratic
nominee and look his delegate hall was
impressive it just didn't give him that
unstoppable lead that so many had been
predicting just a couple of days ago in
fact Sanders even lost a couple of
states that he won easily four years ago
including Oklahoma and Minnesota and
potentially Maine where the race has not
yet been called one of his key arguments
took a hit as well Sanders has been
saying that he is the one who can expand
the electorate in November but Joe Biden
also drove turnout yesterday Super
Tuesday was an even bigger
disappointment for another candidate
Mike Bloomberg he had skipped the first
contest to focus on these races he spent
more than 233 million dollars on ads in
these 14 states and yet he failed to win
a single one of those states outright
and at this point it appears he has only
netted about 31 delegates compared to
hundreds for both Sanders and Biden he
says he's going to spend today
reassessing his campaign but six more
states vote next Tuesday including the
all-important Midwestern state of
Michigan this is a state that Sanders
pulled off a surprise victory in in 2016
he's hoping to repeat next week he has
already traveled to the state eight
times during this primary cycle and he's
heading there again in a couple of days
Anthony all right Nancy thank you